hello welcome back to big mood
i'm nikki i'm tiff i'm gina trying to
figure out where to put this book
and i'm just just get rid of the goddamn
thing get rid of it break up with it
we are bringing back our our breakup
format today where
you submit your situations and we'll
tell you whether or not you should break
up
yeah because our advice trumps anything
else in the world
not the truth not your emotions we
mostly want to
make sure we just don't want you to get
hurt baby yeah
we're your big sisters we're aunties
this would be our advice if you were
coming to us and you were our little
sister
yeah no matter how old you are right
right so i like to preface this by
saying like
don't take advice from people you don't
want to be like so you know obviously if
you don't want to be like us don't take
our advice and our advice isn't um
or do the opposite of yeah whatever life
you like you don't want the most
like do with the opposite of things
right but then you know if you came to
us
this is literally what we would tell you
you came and asked us so you asked
yourself
you asked us it's your fault and if you
have a situation that you would like to
submit sometime in the future be sure
you're following the big mood girl's
instagram
yeah because that is where we are
getting these questions from yes and
also
the dms are open for for everyone not
just women right
true yes yeah men too just men ignoring
all you hot boys out there
little single boys i just do you
remember that song the hot boys song
where am i just bobby shmurda yeah was
it shorter i think
i don't know but it was like that
anyways i'm like now i want to hear it
well i'll play it in between i don't i'm
not yeah look she's pissed
put the volume up in your brain so i can
hear it out of your ears
all right are you ready for the first
situation ladies
i just hope this one won't upset us like
last time because last time we did this
i was
pissed yeah these situations oh you'll
probably be pissed oh lord
usually i i feel like this series is
going to be mostly
at least on my end saying break up yeah
just starts because if you're
questioning yeah i'm already upset
because if it's a girl and she's like
hey i'm kind of having a breakup yeah
you know we'll entertain it yeah pack it
up should you stay or should you go
back to the streets
[Laughter]
that's right i tell them to pack up
their [ __ ] we're going back to the
streets i missed the last time they did
this because i had covet
yeah a [ __ ] loser she's not a nerd
you look so cute you know you talk about
other people's problems you look so cute
when you fake cry
thank you mickey looks like royalty
today look at this i made some choices
like you're not watching this episode
you should look at this we're in
pantalonas right now and
i'm like i'm going to experiment with my
style in the middle of the pescataria
yes pants and fish guys i want to talk
to you like game of thrones this whole
day
you look great the north remembers look
at your grace she looks beautiful today
or like bridgerton whatever i haven't
seen that show but i'm guessing that's
not seen it yet i love it oh i tried to
watch it
anyway okay my boyfriend of five years
spent 48 hours
friday to sunday night with a friend's
younger sister whose birthday it was
break up he basically sorry sorry i'm
trying to i'll hold it back
he basically didn't talk to me the whole
time and admitted to staying up all
night talking with her
this was two weeks after my grandfather
passed away
and when i told my boyfriend while he
was gaming he just sort of went
okay like it was no big deal didn't
console me or pause his game
yeah i've seen that okay first of all we
can't pause some games okay let's lately
yeah
the game started pausing 1997.
well he would he should have allowed
himself to get killed so he could
control his
girlfriend unless it's ranked okay go
ahead this is five years okay
gina's here to take up for the game i
got you guys
okay i've seen the way they text and
talk to each other it's not in a
brotherly friendly way it's very flirty
and sometimes people get mad if i just
see her name pop up on his phone screen
but he tells me i'm just paranoid should
we break
should we break up i think he's cheating
on me with this younger woman she's 19
he's 32. oh he's known her since she was
12.
groomer we have fought too much and many
things are said about him for example
that he
has had sex with some people while he
has been wait sorry that's a different
one
wait wait so which part of the he's
known her since she was 12. should we
break up
girl um oh god
okay so you've brought it up to him
multiple times and not only did he or
was it just the one time during the game
um well he was playing his video game no
that means that was when the grandpa
yeah
what was the beginning of the story
because right now beginning of the story
is that they were together for five
years yeah here's
the facts together for five years this
guy goes and spends
48 hours straight with his friend's
little sister who's
19 whose birthday it was yeah she just
turned 19. they spent 48 hours together
i mean 19 is an important age so
i guess why they celebrated so long no
but then also i want to know more
details like who else was there was it
just the two of them
does it matter though yeah and he didn't
even contact his girlfriend for two days
yeah i don't get caught
i've been missing for two days with a 19
year old and he admitted to staying
up talking all night with her two nights
that's very
that's very it's already even if it's
not sexual it's very intimate
already crossing too many boundaries and
still not communicating with your girl
your girl comes first
communication is good yeah she's
mourning too you [ __ ] [ __ ]
and then instead of reassuring her when
the text messages come up he
gets mad right and says that she's
paranoid that's defensive huge red flags
so many so many red flags and when she
brings it up he
goes yeah like no you don't just have a
problem like that you [ __ ] hug me
yeah he's not there emotionally with you
but he'll spend 48 hours talking with
this other girl and [ __ ]
whatever emotional [ __ ] they're you know
discussing but
when you need it he's not there for it
yeah i think you're a comfort for him
i'm sorry
and i it sucks yeah it sucks just to
hear you because
five years he's just like ah i'm
comfortable
right but i'm not you're not exciting
mm-hmm and also he's
only thinking about getting his own
needs met he doesn't care about what
your needs are
yeah people who don't actively work out
a problem with you instead of just
brushing it off and saying that you're
crazy
not a growth partner not worth it
pack it up back to the streets to the
streets
yeah i think you should go yeah same i
mean i would
i wanted to know more details but
there's obviously
when you want to know more details like
what would make that
situation okay for you i guess so like
if he if he did disappear
for 48 hours you lost kant say it was
your husband you lost contact
with two days the fact that we're
married changes things okay so this is
before you in case you get yeah before
we
disappear because we were together for
five years yeah we got engaged on our
fifth year anniversary but
yeah so i don't know like he disappears
is this a pattern of his that he likes
to hang out with his friends a lot
it usually like you know does he not
just because this one particular girl is
involved like
has he done this in the past like that's
something like weekends where he gets
golfing and then you don't hear from him
exactly and then the fact that this girl
like he's known her since he she was 12.
um so i guess like family friend like
it's his friend's
daught uh sister his friends are jumping
up to a conclusion that it was a sexual
interest at 12 where it could have been
yeah brotherly interest right exactly so
then that's what i'm trying to like
consider right
but then the other factors here were
it's like he's brushing her off he's
getting defensive he's not there for her
when she's mourning like
there's so many other signs there that
is just clearly cut like he doesn't give
a [ __ ] about you
it's easy to jump to conclusions yeah
because everything around the actions
yeah don't sound mature yeah or you know
like
even if he wasn't cheating on you he's
still like being a [ __ ]
yeah and okay honestly let me can i get
can i
ask you guys what's your limit of how
long
you'll wait for a text message yeah i
think that's how long can people go
missing
like like how long can you can you
withstand when it comes to someone
responding to a message
two days no hell no no absolutely not
two days that's very questionable
um after five years together because
even
if because i you know and it's funny
because when we were um
on a trip to playlist in florida a long
time ago
um you weren't there but steve was with
the group he couldn't
he was itching to talk to you like he
couldn't even go
like the the length of the day that you
know like we had a ton of [ __ ] to do
and he was just like i miss my wife i
can't even barely get through this day
like i'm sick of this i wish he was here
like for a man to just be able to so
easily go
two days without finding some sort of
contact with you right to me just as a
red flag and especially seeing someone
like steve have that like you could tell
he physically was just uncomfortable
because he was like it's
it's been six hours i need to go call my
wife like you really
wanted to get in to touch and we've been
together for quite a few years at that
point yeah
you're already married and how many
hours is you guys limit
i'm curious for what for like like not
hearing
a work day it depends on where what he's
doing so when he's writing like he's
usually right in a basement with this
his writing why he's not married oh
dating right if they don't text when i'm
dating uh
like a day like 20 25. you guys are a
lot more lenient
mine is a work day like i know if he's
got an important job he
gets up at eight
guys are very compartmental so like if
they're at work like they're going to be
at work like girls like i think we're a
little bit more
inclined to like do multitasking so like
if he's focused on a task at work i'll
give him the work day
by the evening he needs to respond if
there's no response by the evening
something's [ __ ] wrong right
same yeah for me i guess i'm more
lenient than all of you guys i would
give like
two days yeah cause then like for me
it's like
well again it depends what he's doing it
depends like
when case and i were dating he would be
filming
the whole [ __ ] day like the whole
morning
bet he brushes his teeth like he can't
text while he's [ __ ] at some point no
no i for sure like i would have loved
for him to text me at some point in the
day like you're having lunch like you
couldn't send me a quick like i miss you
like of course right but i wouldn't be
like
i wouldn't be so upset to the point
where i would hold it against him or
whatever like i'd be like oh well [ __ ] i
mean i i get it the day slips away and
you just
you just but it's two days away oh yeah
so like no what i mean by two days it's
like an entire day of filming right and
then he goes to sleep he's [ __ ]
exhausted next morning
he wakes up he has to be editing this
whole [ __ ] video there you go
an entire day eating up again and then
like by that
like second well that makes sense
because his life is project based right
so like you know that in his case
exactly
he will disappear into a hole for two
days and that's his work
flow that's exactly what i mean by
understanding what's happening i
understand when it
hit imagine he was just talking to a
girl
all night that whole time no i'm just
saying like
some people
[Music]
you're just paranoid yeah exactly i'm
just saying everyone takes shits
eventually and you can text while
[ __ ]
see my limit is well i'm needy like
three hours i'm like all right i'll go
[ __ ] myself
then oh [ __ ] yeah three yeah three hours
well well what is i mean you know the
person's lifestyle though right like if
you've been dating for a couple months
you know what their work is like are you
a social media star to where
you know you're gonna film for a couple
hours but you don't have a work day like
everyone else
so what the [ __ ] are you doing that you
can't respond
like exactly and then but not not
everyone owes you
constant communication oh you know like
if you don't text me back but you post
on your story
oh that's oh that's different like when
you know that there's free space there
for them to communicate with you and
they're
choosing to ignore your text yeah post
on social media yeah to me that is a red
flag because they're not just posting on
social media they're scrolling too
and they're actively ignoring you it's
what it feels like they're actively
wearing it is it a powerful
choice right yeah yeah yeah i don't know
but yeah that that
i don't like that guy not me neither i
don't like i was trying to give him
benefit of the doubt but yeah there was
just
there are eggs i like that you did that
though because i do think that there is
some room for
nuance and like you know in this case
though
i don't think so no no
all right to the streets back to the
street back to the streets we got to the
streets am i in the
okay he's 35 i'm 27. i'm a resident
hold on let me do the math 35 27. we're
we're slow on
eight years eight years oh okay um
[Laughter]
35 and 27 i kind of already don't love
it
we haven't even gotten into it let's go
let's go
after 20 okay a woman at 27. man at 35
yeah that's fine you totally maturity
levels years older than you
woman is 27 yeah i can understand either
way
i could get into it right now but i'll
let you finish okay
i'mma let you finish yeah yeah i'm gonna
let you finish first okay
i'm a resident and he is my attending
physician we have been together yes
wait hold on hey wait she's wait what
does this mean i don't understand in the
hospital president they're they're not
training
she's gonna be a doctor this is a power
play right already
oh and she's the what she's the trainer
this is gonna get weird okay yeah so
that when you're a resident you live at
the hospital yeah you're
there all the time right he's working
all these relationships shadowing
especially with your boss is he married
i bet you he's married he's totally
[ __ ] married
you guys okay all right
doing surgery you better text me back
all right so he's put the scalpel down
he's like texting while he's okay
that's a bit much because i want the
girl's body to be sewn up right
okay unless he's cheating on him
[Applause]
he's like i have my hands all up in her
guts why were you inside here you go
inside of her
you have a lot of data docker whatever
um okay we've been together almost
almost one year and in secret
yep during all this time together we
have f probably because the workplace
environment during all his
time together we have fought too much
and many things are said about him for
example that he has had sex with some
people
while he has been with me which is he
has always denied
and on a certain occasion i found a very
sexual conversation with an ex on his
phone
that he said would never happen again
and also that he was not cheating
because it was never physical but i
don't trust him
we continue together despite that and we
decided to commit ourselves to improve
for each other
however he never asks how i am how my
day has been
and when i complain to him he tells me
that this is something that comes
naturally i like him a lot what does
that mean
for her it comes naturally for him it
doesn't oh i see because he's
okay i like him a lot because he is also
very good in bed that's why you're right
but he always says or does things that
make me feel bad emotionally
he emotionally offers me nothing i have
fought
too much oh yeah that's oh nothing okay
i don't know what to do
sorry for my english i am from ecuador
and i love your podcast oh we love you
though
everyone that speaks just fine english
yeah sorry for my english right
yeah you always have great always better
english
believe in yourself don't let it
apologize
that's what i'm trying to say happening
return to the streets
regretted
should we start from the beginning on
this one because
the two sentences that you guys first
had a problem i was angry with
everything we called it already i don't
think there was a sentence i wasn't
upset with
okay honestly
because you have have said yourself that
you'd be oh i'm
very attracted to 42 yeah and i'm 33. i
get it
and okay 26 i feel like your brain's
already fully there
yeah i don't know because she's in this
position now
she's not mature enough to see that this
is a very unhealthy situation even at 27
27 i was still [ __ ] being taken away
dick is good
the guy has a fatherly presence and
emotionally she gets
enough money no nothing yeah so the
emotions is where
it might be your first experience why
does he need to date someone eight years
younger than him though is it because
27 year olds are still moldable and
manipulative
like being able to be manipulated i
think there's a part of that
in there eight years is kind of a lot
when like when a girl's
past her 30s it bothers me less
but i'll just say a girl in her under 30
i still feel like is ripe for
manipulation
you're still vulnerable i think you're
open for manipulation at any age if you
haven't done enough or experienced
enough of course
but i think women under 30 i feel like
we do
reach a point of maturation that at 30.
after third that's all there is a level
of late 20s and mid-20s that i think
still
they they can be taken advantage of a
little bit more and especially by a 35
year old
clearly very intelligent man
who doesn't he said she said he's not
there for her emotionally like
she's just this young hot thing that's
being taken advantage of she doesn't
know if it's normal or not
too right emotionally she's still
at that she's still too young for him he
doesn't
care about you outside the sexual realm
because he doesn't care to check in on
you see if you're okay
check on your day how are you and you
said emotionally he gives you nothing i
mean the fact that you can even say that
about yeah
you're dating is like what are you
looking for personally then
clearly you're not looking for that this
just sounds like the hot workplace
fling that should have never gone past
like maybe [ __ ] two or three times and
that's
it he's bill clinton you're the moniker
and he slept with other people there
like
oh you know that doctor's banging all
the [ __ ] hot residents yeah and
they're probably on different [ __ ]
timetables and [ __ ] he's probably got
different troops roses schedules yeah
and good dicks a dime a dozen you can
find it anywhere girl you don't have to
[ __ ] that's not true but okay
yeah they say good deck is is abundant
but it's it's not they're different
you've had good dick then good dick is
not abundant dick is very
dick is regular dick is like so abundant
it's beyond it's beyond clearance
have you seen the bruises have you seen
the bruises i haven't
shown me but anyways yeah i mean my dick
bruised you
from the inter cervix that sucks i hate
that
but yeah and then the power dynamic
because of the fact that he's
the physician she's the resident
yeah you're being used this can get ugly
yeah
i think you're being used yeah so for
sure back to the streets on this one um
but before you go back to the streets
pack the clothes you should buy some new
clothes
hell yeah how are we gonna get those
clothes we gonna get those clothes we're
gonna get those clothes on stitch fix
is it convenient oh my gosh please say
it is so convenient i actually bought my
shoes on stitch fix i
talked about these last week or i think
i can't remember when but recently i
actually you can on stitch fix everyone
knows it as a subscription box where the
the stylist will
come up with some cute [ __ ] you'll rate
like yes or no on some stuff online
they'll come up with some cute [ __ ] and
send it straight to your door
um but you can actually also just buy
stuff directly off the website they have
like
little curated outfits you can buy that
whole outfit or you can just like say oh
i like the shoes or i just like the
purse or i like that jacket like you can
pick out certain things the equivalent
of like buying what's on the mannequin
right yeah exactly and i love that
because i have a hard time putting
together outfits
so the service is very helpful for
someone like me um
so yes you can try on the pieces at home
before you buy keep what you love and
return when you don't uh they make it
super easy to return they
they ship you the return package with it
so you just close up the bag and drop it
off
there's a 20 20 styling fee for each box
but it gets credited towards the pieces
you keep
there are no hidden fees ever stitch fix
also
styles men women and kids and they ship
all over the u.s
and in the uk um so if you want to try
out stitch fix which i highly recommend
get started today
at stitchfix.com mood you'll get 25
off when you keep everything in your box
that's stitchfix.com
for 25 off when you keep everything in
the fix
stitchfix.com mood
yeah look sharp yeah oh i love that
i like that that's my favorite
transition of the day
it looks sharp as as sharp as wait what
i'm gonna go [ __ ] myself i gave you guys
gold earlier but if i missed it
sorry nicki wins sorry
uh so anyway look at sharp as a meson
knife it's a chef's knife and this knife
is so
freaking sleek and it's sharp and
precise and it's so elegant it has this
like unique sloped
handle that not only allows you to chop
more efficiently easily and safely but
the elegant design makes you want to
show it off rather than just stashing it
in a drawer yeah let's be honest a lot
of knives are very
much the same but this one is actually
very pretty i like the blue color of the
handle
the metal is looks very expensive we buy
things because they're
they're expensive and they're nice and
it's japanese so you know that's just
good
they actually they they've said that
it's designed to replace every knife
that you have
exactly an entire set of knives and
you guys know like a dull knife it's
actually a dangerous knife it'll make
slicing things a lot like harder to get
through
yeah it's slippery yeah my dad always
told me that it's more dangerous when
you have to put more force behind
right something than if it glides easier
yeah and just makes cooking more
difficult but then with the mison chef's
knife
you can slice through anything like
butter it is
amazing tension yeah and then also the
weight of of this knife it's just
it's just really well balanced i'm a fan
mison is two to three times less
expensive than other premium knife
brands
for the same amazing quality and
mieson's knives are crafted with
high grade stainless steel so they can
stay sharper longer and last a lifetime
all for a fraction of the competitor's
costs the mison
chef's knife is legit and verified it
has over 5 000
5 star reviews from real pro chefs
and also has a cult following among home
chefs and foodies
so step up your cooking game now and
head over to meeson.com
big mood for 20 off your first order
that's
m i s e n dot com slash
big mood for 20 off your first order
meeson.com big mood yeah my dad's a chef
i've always had it drilled into me like
what kind of knives you're supposed to
buy
yeah it passed your test so i was like
all right it's a good yeah that's a good
night
hell yeah okay this situation i feel
like is kind of a common one with
couples and i also think it might have
to do with like your background and your
like culturally and stuff
so me the person submitting 24
him 27. do you have a problem yes i'm
okay with the three you're done okay
okay i just want to check sorry no no
problem but yes i'm okay with it three
years is good
all right past the age test with jess um
together since may 2018
so almost three years now okay he wants
kids i don't oh
he only wants kids because that's just
tradition not because he actually loves
children
oh no i've openly said to him i never
want kids
i think he's hoping i'll change my mind
one day but he's trying to attract
a [ __ ] sorry i especially wouldn't want
kids with someone who doesn't genuinely
love children yeah
is this relationship just going nowhere
if we disagree on this
keep me anonymous thanks okay i'm a
little bit scared because
and i don't want to i i'm very prone to
making lean in i'm very prone to making
men um
an enemy here but it's scary to me when
a guy's like i don't really want kids
but i feel like i need to have them like
for
you know looks or whatever like you're
gonna be his [ __ ]
you're gonna do all the [ __ ] work yep
you don't even
want the kids yourself yeah you're the
one not wanting the kids
absolutely not it's very weird to me
when a guy's like oh i just need kids
like
socially yeah it's such a weird reason
to bring a
life into the world it's like a trap
it's like a bear trap
built in trauma definitely like yeah
think of what if your parents told you
yeah we had you just because we felt
like we had to
you know like it's a thing to do
societally we had like it was culturally
yeah that's what we had to do oh no
that's a big yikes hell no runaway girl
yeah that
relationship is not going anywhere and
even if he decides to like
change his mind later on because he
realizes like oh yeah you know
it wouldn't be a good idea to have kids
i feel like there's
other issues in there that you might not
seen maybe or that you haven't
recognized but
if he's already approaching this
children issue that way that just tells
me there's other things
buried in there yeah the way his mind
works is maybe not
you're not on the same page with yeah
and that's more important actually
it's like the way he got to that exactly
and you don't
it's very strange for me that his brain
works like
i have to do this giant thing
just because society yeah how influenced
you
by society that you're willing to bring
a whole new life that would cost so much
goddamn money
you know just because other people say
you should like oh it's time
right i guess we have to do that one
thing yeah procreate whole another
life there like a whole other existence
that you are going
to be bringing into this world just so
you can
use them as an accessory it's [ __ ]
gross like does everyone
does everyone need to have kids no
realistically honestly
does everyone like no no not at all
especially if she's not inclined to be a
mother
he only wants them because they're
supposed to check a box
like not everyone needs to have kids
yeah i'm actually really glad that our
american culture at least is shifting in
the direction where it's like
not unacceptable to not have kids yeah
oh we don't know what they are
yeah right because she said that his
background
like his culture culturally or or in his
tradition his family tradition
so like cultural tradition right um
that's how it is
in his back that just tells me that
culturally probably and that
like and for his family tradition the
men and the family
don't have to do anything don't they're
not involved in their
their children's life at all so then i
don't even understand why he would go
with the girl that is
has been very vocal about not wanting to
find one that wants to be a baby maker
there's so many women that do want kids
too yeah that's very strange
very strange i don't know maybe couples
who broke up because they had differing
wants so i was gonna ask like if it
wasn't this whole like he doesn't love
kids like
let's say it's he genuinely genuinely
wants kids and
and you don't like absolutely same
answer yeah
there's really no way around it this is
a huge thing it's not one of those like
well i like spicy food she doesn't this
is huge
because either one or two things gonna
happen either you have kids and
you resent him forever and the kids can
you imagine her not even wanting to be a
mother him not lifting a finger and then
she has to be
left with them right right no or you
don't have kids and
he resents you forever maybe he ends up
even seeking
this desire somewhere else he's gonna
spread his seed on the side
jeez i imagine it like a butter knife
for some reason
like i pictured like seeds in his hand
that he's tossing into a field
none of us pictured a dick okay i've
changed my stance on children
oh yeah you want do you want something
now because you're always flipping your
flap
she called them children yeah but then
she'll be like oh but then this one
like you know i maybe i do want kids so
i'm confused
i do want children okay you do i want
multiple
uh i just don't want to be the one that
has to birth them so surrogate
okay so if any of you guys are i'm kind
of
i'm kind of with you on that like i
don't want to birth a child but
recently and i don't know if it's just a
pandemic talking um but i've
i've been more okay with the idea of
like adopting an
orphan child yeah but i just can't see
myself
ever birthing one i don't know how you
did it girl well she had a c-section
yeah so i didn't really know but you you
had the babies like you made the baby
yeah that process is already so
difficult
for me i want to be pregnant yeah yeah
yeah yeah but i don't want it to come on
my face
yeah i think we're about to do the same
thing stop all the nutrients out of your
body
so my favorite thing to do recently is
to uh tell steve that i want something
random like
cinnamon rolls or taco bell like i get
random cravings like
recently and i'll tell them it's for the
baby right
but the baby that's not here yet we're
not pregnant
but it could be we don't know at any
point
you never know yeah it's one of those
hoodies with the zipper and the cats are
in there we have sex for the baby
if you never take a pregnancy test
you'll never know
but exactly i'm okay with being pregnant
i think it'd be a cute pregnancy right
we could have photo shoots
let's do it at the same time but then
just like somehow transplant it yeah
to a surrogate to actually like birth
yeah yeah yeah yeah oh what if they come
up with that technology in the future
because you know how they came up with
that
like there's like a sack where there was
a baby sheep that they actually
yeah embryo and then like all the way to
being
birthed but it was all in like this bag
but what if they create something where
you can wear it
have the baby with you you look like a
cockroach where it's clear and you can
see what's happening
yeah baby bag and just oh that'd be so
cool no this is disgusting
i don't like it it's unnatural right i
love that party pooper
like we could see it forming make fun of
it
look at its dumb little pants shaking oh
but then i wonder how it would develop
with like such bright light right right
right and like the different
environments come out like powder
[ __ ] that reference is far too old
i'm sorry
just let's move on all right next
question okay so i'll try to make this
short i'm currently on a break almost
three weeks with my boyfriend
we've been together for a year and five
months we're both 26
they're both the same age don't worry
jess i'm a scorpio he's a sagittarius oh
geez fire in water yikes so basically
yeah right shut up okay you're firing
water right there
actually yeah you you and her uh-huh
okay okay
and we're firing water scorpion yeah
that's actually us
oh okay we're on a break okay sorry
weeks haven't seen rails water yeah
definitely not 26 of them i'm letting
you guys know that right now so yeah you
don't know
you see my birth certificate i know we
look younger though
and a half wait sorry we've been
fighting too much so they've been
together for a year
a year and five months a year and a half
and they're taking no a year and five
months okay you're in five months
they're taking a three-week break
they've been on a three almost a
three-week break okay okay
and and she's a scorpio he's a
sagittarius
reason so okay so basically bad guys
like sorry really quick
i don't know you know horoscope stuff i
know i don't
know what i dated she only knows the
ones that she knows okay so basically my
boyfriend has always been pretty good to
me
and our relationship has been good okay
but after we had been dating for
four months i asked him if i could use
his laptop
and that's when i found his instagram
was open and i saw all the saved
pictures
of girls he had i was obviously very
upset and i told him how she stayed with
him for another year
and a month after that anyway okay let's
hear the rest of this i got questions um
i was obviously very upset and i told
him how i felt and he was very sorry and
he said he would get rid of them and
stop following all the girls he didn't
know
so i forgave him that same night and
anyway he didn't actually end up
deleting all of them until like
december of last year but he would
always tell me he was done looking at
pictures
and i understand that he's going to find
other girls attractive i understand that
it's just that some of the pictures were
of girls i recognized as girls
in from our area oh no yeah
and so three weeks ago i checked his
phone while i was next to him to see if
he liked pictures which i never did this
before and this was probably the second
time that i had um
i honestly didn't think i would find
anything but i clicked on his activities
and that's when i saw he had been
clicking on girls links and looking at
their pictures
one of them was a girl he knows anyway i
made him leave that night and now
i don't really know what to do he
actually started going to a therapist to
see how he could make himself a better
person because he says he still wants a
future with me but i'm afraid of getting
hurt again
sorry if it's too long i would really
appreciate any advice you guys are the
best
do you have receipts for these therapy
sessions
just kidding i mean i can just be
sitting in the mcdonald's you know
parking lot and saying i went to therapy
i have mixed opinions but i want to hear
you guys kidding on that okay so if it
was like
random like instagram model celebrities
that's pretty
fine like you know i guess yeah but if
it's girls in your area and that they
kind of know that's weird that's that's
that's um yeah and also i guess okay
is it not creepy though to imagine a guy
having an instagram and he's following
like a thousand [ __ ] girls and he's
just ogling all these women
yeah and it's not even like it's weird
too because it's like not even porn it's
just like he's just
so like why does he have time to be
looking at all these other women all the
time like why is that such a focus of
his day is that he's looking at all
these other women all like he's got a
woman at
home yeah like why does he need so much
access to so many pretty girls all
like wait i feel like we've normalized
it a little bit too much yeah yeah
i agree did he follow these girls he'd
probably follow these girls before he
met her probably yeah right and then
when she first found it
like foreign that situation where it was
like he still kind of had it like that
seems like acceptable to me he was
single before that yeah so that's fine
when you're single it's [ __ ] fine
but then they had a conversation about
it and he still didn't do it and he said
he apologized admitted it was wrong and
then said he wouldn't do it again
that's scary and that's the fact that he
crossed that boundary
that's the part i have a problem with is
that he lied about it and continued to
do it
and had some sort of fake um
show of like remorse and regret
and all of that but the whole time he
was just still doing it like i feel like
kind of scary to have a fake show of
remorse and regrets
he got caught like and he doesn't want
to lose her because he doesn't want to
ruin a good thing just because of this
like
little habit he has on the side i've
learned that apologies without action
is just manipulation yeah that's what it
is yeah rectify it
how do you guys feel about um yeah i'll
look but i'll never touch
because i feel like there's levels to it
yeah there's levels to looking there's
like if you see a hot girl at the
grocery store
in the milk aisle and you're like damn
that girl's kind of banging and then you
just go on about your day but then
if your evening routine consists of
taking a [ __ ] and just like staring at a
bunch of hot chicks
it's like yeah it's still sticking it's
kind of creepy okay but he's not acting
upon it
like because a part of me it's just like
it's human nature
to look right but you know so long as
you don't
kind of in the real world though kind of
like you know like
you're at work there's a hot girl that
comes into your office or whatever
you're like oh damn she's beautiful you
know and then you kind of go on about
your day but like
there's something kind of with this
online
because it's an action still like what
you're saying gina like it
them looking up online like that is the
action of going and
clicking on their links yeah thinking of
them so now it's gone past the like oh
i'm just looking
now you're thinking of them you're
actively like a habit going to find them
the pictures right yeah and it's like a
concentrated
um activity where you're like now i'm in
my
um part of the day where now i'm
ogling over half naked women and it
feels like it's a departure from the
relationship yeah because what other
reason do you have to save pictures
to jerk off other than to revisit them
yeah exactly
i feel that that with liking pictures
too why do you need to like their photo
yeah it's like it's like you're just
looking it's a form of interaction where
it's like hey i'm here just
you know i'm here you i'm going to like
you and you're like maybe there's a
chance you'll see my life
right like they're like what's the
thought behind liking something like
i like y'all [ __ ] all the time because i
want y'all to see my name on it like i
support you i support you yeah exactly
so i'm too popular on instagram so i
can't see all the likes it's just [ __ ]
i know you see my name is the first
three i know it says my name and then
ten thousand
other people i know you're gonna see my
name i know you're gonna see my name
that's why i make sure to comment too
you're gonna see me
yeah but i don't know i mean doesn't it
feel like we've reached a point where
interfering it's too much but it's like
so
normalized i'm happy to be married to a
guy that doesn't understand social media
he can't even
he doesn't know how to check dms i've
had to teach him five times
how to check dm's because someone from
our real life will be like how come
you're not responding to our my dms
and then he's like i don't know how to
get to them that's funny
i show him so many times yeah so i'm
like yeah i find it
i find it refreshing that a guy wouldn't
have
1700 instagram thoughts and and his list
of follows and then like 10 of his
buddies
i when i see that i'm like yeah
i don't like it nope yeah and i don't
think we really need to explain
why and i feel like society's like
pressures you into saying being
being like okay with it well look but
it's just weird
everyone's going to feel differently
about it and as long as you're with
someone that matches those values for
example
i wouldn't want to be in an open
relationship as long as i'm not with
somebody that wants to be in an open
relationship
then we're good yeah like if you have
those urges you just
like that guy needs to be with some
other girl who's like
totally free-spirited and like chill
with it but if you are at any point
uncomfortable
with what your partner is doing and you
don't think you are in alignment or see
eye to eye
on what your values are or the for like
the moving forward
it's just not gonna work like at some
point it's just gonna you're gonna
be fed up with it you're gonna resent
each other and it's gonna fester it's
just not a healthy start to a
relationship
and i do think a year and four months is
the start of a relationship still
that's a lot of time for her to have
invested in this guy too so i'm sure
she's just like trying to make
excuses we're like well this is kind of
really the only thing
everything else is okay actually a year
is and five months is such a short time
i know but it feels like a lot of
investment like i dated a guy for
seven weeks and that felt like an
investment i was like you know i you
know the especially in the beginning
you're giving yourself
so much to this person to get to that
point of trust that you feel at
your three that first year is just you
you're dumping your whole life your
emotions your feelings like that's a
it feels like a lot in the first year
for sure you don't want it to go away
but know that like they had to invest
just as much time so
and they ruined it yeah true yeah they
made their own so they
lost a year and a half and you're
already on a break oh geez
yeah i would say already after stay on
that break yeah
per minute and he says he's getting help
but like
i mean do you want to he said he would
he deleted the pictures before like i
don't know i just don't really trust
i feel like the trust is already broken
for sure and it's really hard to build
that trust
so do you really want to put the work
into it because if you don't walk away
you know what else is broken
uh my hair back then when it was dry as
heck but not from all the bleach
yeah well the bleach [ __ ] we got a lot
of bleach in our hair but not anymore
because of function of beauty
it's a personalized hair care and body
care
brand it's a world leader in
customizable
beauty offering precise formulations for
your hair specific needs
i like things that give me quizzes so
you go on their site you take a quiz on
what your hair is like and then what you
want your hair to look like
and they will formulate a uh a formula
for you
for your hair and what you need and then
you can also choose your color and your
fragrance or you can go fragrance and
die free
then function's team determines the
perfect blend bottles your formula
even labels it with your name on it
every ingredient function of beauty uses
is vegan and cruelty free and they never
use sulfates or parabens
you can also go completely silicone free
there are 54 trillion possible
formulations and
that's a lot functional beauty offers
completely personalized formulas for
body and skin care as well so you can
customize your beauty routine from hair
to toe i like that
that's cute i actually got their serum
too yeah and their travel kit but
yeah i put the serum in my hair too yeah
i use it every time it's having the
moving conditioner in right now
yeah and also the lotion i'm such a fan
oh yeah the lotion's really nice i
already used up all my lotion really
fast oh what were you doing
don't ask questions you don't want the
answer to
so never buy off the shelf just to be
disappointed ever again
go to functionbeauty.com big mood to
take your quiz and save 20
on your first order that applies to
their full range of customized hair
skin and body products go to
functionalbeauty.com
big mood to let them know that we sent
you and to get 20 off your order
again that's functionalbeauty.com big
moon
that is why my hair smells like roses
yeah and you can
um smell like roses while you're on your
zoom meeting with
uh a therapist talking about your
problems or maybe
the guy in this i think we know someone
that could use stock space
who the guy's
right hopefully he's like talking to the
therapist because he has
access uh via a mobile device or a
computer perhaps
uh talk space is the number one online
therapy platform that has thousands of
licensed
therapists trained in over 40
specialties including anxiety depression
relationships and more
your therapist can help you set and
achieve your goals it's affordable
it's a fraction of the cost of in-person
therapy which is
very costly and instead of waiting for
an appointment you can send unlimited
messages to your therapist 24 7 and
they'll engage with you daily five days
a week so sometimes like if you're
having
anxiety on monday but your appointment's
not thursday but you're like i just need
to get it out because on thursday you're
like i don't have anxiety what are you
talking about
and then you don't actually get to heal
yeah okay they have a therapist network
thousands of licensed therapists with
years of experience and over 40
specialties which i mentioned
uh easy to switch to it's very easy it's
so
fast and easy you're like next you get
to see all the credentials and pick the
one that suits you best
exactly or if you just don't sometimes i
get i get very impatient with people if
they take too long to talk
i'm like i gotta go next yeah you're
milking this hour for me yeah
um anyway secure talk space is secure
and private
using the last uh the latest end-to-end
bank grade encryption technology i don't
know what that is but it sounds pretty
pretty secure safe your private stuff
won't get
exactly and as a listener of this
podcast you'll get a hundred dollars off
your first month with talkspace
to match with a licensed therapist today
go to talkspace.com or download the app
make sure to use the code mood to get a
hundred dollars off your first month
and show your support for the show
that's mood m-o-o-d
and talkspace.com that's a lot of
no hairs that's right okay
so i mean do did we finish the feeling
though on this guy getting therapy
because some people might be like oh you
guys are too mean no yeah just going in
there elaborate a little bit more
on that part because yeah the easy route
is to just completely cut ties with this
guy especially if you're not i mean
depending on where you
exactly feel with him like do you feel
like you're completely in love
and like willing to work hard for this
relationship like do all of his
prose exactly wait is this the only con
right right right exactly so take every
take the entire relationship into
consideration and
obviously you have if you're already on
a break and
ask yourself like what does that break
really mean to you like do you really
genuinely believe that he is seeking
help do you feel like he will actually
change his ways in the future and you
can actually rebuild that trust because
i know for a fact it's [ __ ]
hard it's like climbing mount everest to
get trust back in a relationship
it's really fun i don't know if i've
ever trusted someone that i've
not trusted for a certain event like i
don't know if i've ever
trusted someone again so for me that
would be harder but for other people it
might not be
yeah i mean yeah it's really
difficult to move past that and grow but
then also like
like i said if you're taking the entire
relationship into consideration and you
feel like it's something you can really
work
towards work for then
in the end and also if you feel like he
is in the same page
and saying like you know what i know i'm
really [ __ ] up it's just like this
this like habit of mine that i've had
for many years or whatever it is and
like i
will also can't let's give him a little
bit of credit that society does
normalize it exactly he probably doesn't
feel like it's that big of a problem
exactly and it totally is but it still
is a problem
even though society says it's not it's
still not healthy behavior
yeah so we could give him a chance to
like see that
understand that and maybe like rethink
it yeah exactly
yeah and that's what i i think he is
already taking the first steps if he
really is going to therapy is by going
to therapy
and like see like understanding that
that is something
in his life that he wants to change to
keep you around right and like to to
work on the relationship so i don't know
it's just really
analyzing the level of commitment that
you both have for the relationship and
seeing
if there is even a future there that is
worth fighting for
i like to say like trust your gut
because i think you're gonna know like
is he really down for you or are you
kind of
also ignoring some other red flags you
don't feel super
secure with him but you're like oh on
paper he's so great and i just yeah you
know it's hard to find good guys so
should i really let this one go like
really just really your guy will tell
you we have
our intuition we need to not ignore it
nope
it's there to guide you all right so
we're not packing our bags
i don't know however packing bags
optional
optional i mean the bags are kind of
already packed they've been separated
that's true you're 26 you're a long way
to go
you could use this relationship as a
lesson like give it another year
and then you see like what happened when
you did that route
right uh but personally i'm i just
i'm just too many lines i'm like i've
been there and i don't want to do it
again
it scares me a little bit because like
when he found it he wasn't kind of like
wait what's i thought it was fine like
he he didn't know
like oh i'm so sorry i won't do it again
and then live that's what bothers me it
feels malicious yeah anything that
my partner would be too scared to do in
front of me
to me they know they're doing something
wrong and they're doing it anyway
right and that's more of a problem to me
than than them just doing the thing
yeah you know right yeah it's like
that's betrayal
actions behind this stupid little
behavior but it's like there's
it's a bigger choice that he's making by
hiding and yeah
what else is what's next you know now
it's this little thing of him looking at
pictures but what's next
and that's exactly what i mean by like
that mount everest of trust that you
have to climb because every moment
you're always constantly suspicious or
you're thinking like
wait like is he telling the truth this
time because you've lied to me already
in the past you said that you were done
and you
acknowledged it was wrong but then how
am i how am i going to build the trust
to
to believe you again after time and time
like it's already happened once will it
happen again and then what happens after
that time like
it's just exhausting pull me twice
situation it's [ __ ] exhausting that's
why i'm like girl
analyze it are you ready for all that
work because it's gonna be [ __ ] work
and i personally don't think that we
need to raise men i think they don't
know they need to figure this [ __ ] out
yeah so like they need to do their own
work quality
man we don't we don't need to do the
work for them we're not their moms
exactly so i don't know just that [ __ ]
is exhausting
because me i'm an overthinker god damn
that [ __ ] sucks yeah and then it's like
would he be this way if it wasn't
the middle of a panera bread right right
right exactly it's true
no it's not a panera bread that's a
children's doctor
yes you're right you're right all right
okay this one's a little bit
longer okay um but hey girls love the
podcast
i would appreciate if my name isn't
mentioned during the podcast all right
anonymous
uh but i've only dated my boyfriend for
four months however we've known each
other for almost two years already
my boyfriend tells me that he wants to
he wants me to be his last girlfriend
but i kind of doubt it because he still
gets updates about his ex-girlfriend
which they dated for about a year
and i'm a pretty busy person but i work
school and watch my younger siblings so
i make time for him when i can
but he'll get mad saying i never make
time for him and if he doesn't plan
anything then i would never hit him up
which is so false because i tried my
best to make him happy and go see him
whenever i can
anytime every time we argue it's always
about how he's putting in 95 out of 100
and i'm only putting 5 out of 100 into
the relationship
i really love him but i find myself
extremely exhausted on how to make him
happy
i'm a really shy person so i usually
follow by lead but he doesn't understand
that
he always makes me feel guilty for not
spending time with him i also come from
a traditional family which they're
strict on me going out so often
however i do bend the rules for my
boyfriend and go see him when i can
yeah he doesn't see any effort in it he
also gets mad when i spend time with my
family and when we talk on the phone
if i don't talk to him as much he'll get
upset about it too he really is my
first or he's my first real boyfriend so
i really like and love him he doesn't
post pictures
about me much and he often posts
pictures of his korean celebrities
saying
how much he likes them or how bae they
are
i know i shouldn't get mad at that but
he makes me feel insecure sometimes i
often find myself apologizing to him
more than
how he does to me he also posts pictures
of his
girlfriends saying miss you or post
posting his old memories when he
traveled saying take me back
when i didn't stress which during those
times he wasn't with me because he cut
me off
when we talk about this he says i'm his
babe and his only babe
i really want to believe it because he's
nice and cooks for me when i visit him
and tries to engage me into things too
but then again he often calls me weird
and awkward i'm trying my best to see
good in this relationship
but i really do because i really do
enjoy spending time with him but
to him i'm not doing enough what should
i do
personally it sounds to me like she's
not communicating a lot
yeah i i'm assuming especially the way
she wrote it it just sounds like
like he's he's like hello
are you there and then she's just like
she's putting in the effort on her end
but
she's not communicating with the effort
right so for him he's like what the [ __ ]
she doesn't care like
she's only spending her time with her
friends or whatever and
like i'm only focused on that part right
now because the other part i'm like
that's that's weird
with the posting on social media about
his girlfriends and then not her
like that's a little weird seems like a
difference in love languages honestly
that's what i'm saying yeah he seems
like a quality time love language and
she's
an acts of service or something i don't
know he gets upset when she spends time
with her family though
there's some weird little thing that i'm
wondering if this is some sort of a
possessive issue
because if she can communicate to us
strangers
i feel like i'm doing everything that i
can't like i don't
know is she completely incapable of
saying like hey i feel like i'm doing my
best i have work i have
school i have but what about like i feel
like if she can communicate that very
quite eloquently to us
i kind of doubt that she can't just say
hey i feel like i'm putting in my part
i disagree i think that it's easier to
communicate to others especially when
you're writing it out
versus someone that you actually care
for face to face
and or even through text or whatever
because there's like a different
dynamic there so i personally disagree
with that i think it is easier for her
to communicate to us
her situation versus her own boyfriend
and she also did make it clear that she
was a shy person so i'm trying to think
like a shy person
that is constantly busy is putting in
the effort to try to see her boyfriend
but the boyfriend doesn't feel
like she is there's a very obvious clear
um like lack of communication in
communication
yeah in my opinion something bothered me
though about him not liking her spending
time with her family
and that it's only been four months yeah
that like
i don't like that's a new relationship
there's a thing in my gut that says i
don't like that behavior because that's
the behavior of someone that will take
over your whole life
yeah for sure and we're starting to see
just tiny pieces of it
and it's so small to where she's like
she can excuse it she's like well i know
i'm busy
there's some signs of narcissism for
sure yeah like him saying that he's
putting all the effort
into her like she's getting her into a
little trap like yeah you know trying to
take her away from her making her feel
guilty
yeah into a way where she's blaming
herself now i'm just scared of that i
don't know
if that's their situation yeah
definitely valid bother me
i felt a little bit weird about her
describing that
to me it kind of sounded a little um
a little like i don't know did she
mention ages um
because they sound like high school
college to me it does sound young
it was her first real boyfriend right
yeah so for that reason i'm thinking
high school boy um feeling like he's not
getting enough of his girlfriend he
she's probably not communicating the
effort
and but he does see that she's able to
make time
for her friends and family which
obviously are very important and she
should be
able to have time for them but me
placing myself in his shoes i would
i could see how he would get jealous or
feel like
like am i not important enough for you
to also spend time with me not
necessarily like don't spend time with
your friends and
family but more like where's the wife he
comes across that way because he's
immature still i think so
that's what i'm concluding yeah it could
be yeah
yeah but i understand his side like
wanting more
time together and stuff like that um
but i also want to go on the other side
like you guys are thinking
maybe she's not good at communication
what if she does communicate it and he's
just not receptive to it at all
yeah that's another thing yeah for sure
also um that he doesn't post pictures of
her but he posts pictures of that is
pretty weird
a little manipulative he won't even post
about her right
yeah and then if he and she said that
they were they weren't together
right like four months ago oh it was so
much better performance yeah like
there seems to be some weird
manipulative things right but there's
they're so small where you could be like
you could cover it up easily and be like
oh no you're crazy that's not even the
case at all but then
when you kind of start taking them all
in it starts to feel like
it makes your gut feel something but
it's not obvious enough for it to
for you to be justified yeah right right
yeah that's what further adds to the
high school theory for me because i feel
so [ __ ] high the fact that she even
submitted
means like her gut is telling her
something right and the whole like
posting korean celebrities thing i can
kind of let that pass
like if you're posting a-list
celebrities and junk that's fine i think
it's less about
uh what what he's posting but more just
like
and i don't know if it's been a
conversation that she's like i wish he
posted more pictures of me and he
doesn't
um but the captions it seems like are
more hurtful
like this is when i was struggling that
one yeah but then like if you're posting
pictures of like
k-pop stars like he is he's like oh
that's bae i don't really i'm not
yeah i mean like because i'll post a
picture of tom hardy and be like oh
[ __ ] take me right
seven ways right but i mean obviously
like that has nothing to do with someone
i'm dating like that's just like a silly
fan thing so i get that but yeah it's
like he'll post with other friends and
stuff
like oh this was this was a better time
in my life and
when you post that publicly it does make
the person you're with now i feel like
well
your life's not good now like yeah
that's uh that's that
is a very obvious sign of
petty moves like trying to hurt you
because he's hurt right kind of moves
like he's getting it he wants attention
but he's doing it in a petty way exactly
like he's like well maybe this is how
she'll notice me and give me some sort
of attention but he probably doesn't
even
actually like know that he's doing right
it's like some subconscious petty [ __ ]
but going back to exploring the fact
that maybe she is
expressing herself and saying like hey
you know i had to go to work or whatever
i came straight
over here even though my parents say i
have to go home or whatever she's
actually communicating the effort that's
being put in he's not
receiving that that's a whole nother
problem there right
like he's that and that it falls into
the possessive
narcissistic realm of he's just
probably never gonna get enough of you
then and you're just gonna exhaust
yourself in this relationship and he's
just gonna constantly want more and more
and more from you and that's
[ __ ] up because i'm needy as hell but
i can still understand like okay you
have work and you have family and stuff
like that and i know
what things come before me you know
to a certain extent obviously you can
just push me all the way to the side but
and then if he's communicating with you
like oh you know
i'm so sorry i wanted to come but i
couldn't because of this and this and
that
that's a whole yeah it really boils down
to communication like how i am with text
messages
if you can't text me for like five hours
all you have to say is hey i'm gonna do
this for the next five hours
yeah and i'll be totally fine you know
but if you just don't say anything then
that's when it's a problem so this might
be a huge communication problem but then
also on his side he might not be
receptive at all to this yeah well and
if she's too
shy like you're saying to even be able
to like when you're gonna be in a
relationship maybe if you're really
young like you need to know this now and
understand this now you have to be able
to talk to the person you're with
otherwise you're not really in a
relationship exactly
and talking to them doesn't necessarily
mean you're going to start an argument
you can literally just be like hey
can i talk to you about something
explain how you feel
it's not a fight it's explaining how you
feel and if it feels like they make it
into a fight then they're not receptive
and this is not healthy
yeah because there's inevitably going to
be issues like yeah and you it's more
your relationship is
the health of a relationship is more
based on how you resolve those issues
than it is about
never fighting exactly holy [ __ ] because
never fighting that's just avoidance and
resentments being built and your
unhappiness is being built too so
don't [ __ ] do that don't think that
by avoiding a problem you're helping the
problem you're not you're making it
worse
even just little things i i bring up to
steve like i told you guys i was having
like
dreams of like going on first dates with
guys
like randomly i would just like four
dreams in a row of like random guys
just like going on those a first date
and i don't even remember their faces
but just that feeling of like
yeah oh it's like how do i look and like
the first date and so i even told steve
that i was like
do you think like we should like do more
romantic things or something like what's
like
why am i having these dreams and like
the fact that he was like oh yeah maybe
we should and so
he's like oh i'll plan a date and it's
like yeah
those things add up over time where
you're not just like brushing over them
you're not just like
pondering them to yourself you're
getting them out in the open and then
you're working together on like
oh how do we make this better for us
right that's so true because even within
your own self
like let's say something something
happened
and you were bothered by it and then you
think you got over it
but you actually really didn't but you
didn't know that you didn't get over it
yeah
yeah it's repressed it comes up in other
ways and it's just
it's like it's like um venom for your
relationship like don't do that start
getting snappy
don't get in the habit of not bringing
up what's bothering you right
mm-hmm i have another one and this one
what's the conclusion for this oh yeah
i mean i think they're really young and
they're very they need to work on their
communication skills and like setting
expectations
um and she just needs to watch his
behavior to see if it's going to be
increasingly possessive exactly
or if he's or you know can she is there
something she can do to like
make it more 50 50 or yeah i think this
is at the red flag stage like you're
seeing
some red flags but we need more
information more time
and then also it's her first
relationship so i personally think it
it's
healthy to learn from this yeah so see
what else i don't think they're going to
stay together forever
but it's a good learning training wheels
relationship
right maybe it ends up being more but
you know
i mean i don't think anyone should stay
with their first boyfriend anyway you
need life experience
that's my personal opinion it's your
personal opinion i agree with it but
that's your personal opinion
i agree with you actually um i actually
okay so we say we're saying stick it out
see what happens learn from it
yeah yeah but like be wary be wary of
possessive behavior or manipulative
behavior but
try try to get better at talking about
it yeah yeah also make sure that you're
doing your
best at communicating too then go from
there so this one i
i just picked to see just get mad okay
you picked it just to piss me off
yeah all right i'm 19. my boyfriend's
52.
i'm gonna burn this whole place down
let's just be the one she's like not mad
at all right
right there's probably no submission
that i'm not going to be upset about
it's true
let's be honest i'm on the i'm on the
defense
been in a situationship quote for about
a year and a half now
a year and a half oh i'm already bad
when we actually do things together go
out travel drink
everything is great and we have a really
good time but when we're just at his
house together
he wants me to do wifey things cook
clean
laundry go get his food no no for him
but he never does anything for me
except occasionally buying me food that
i have to go pick up and
quote unquote gives me dick in his words
not mine
he even says that even though we're not
in a relationship
i get almost sick to my stomach lose my
appetite etc when he talks about not
talking anymore or other girls
i feel like things are starting to get
really toxic but i just can't stop
talking to him
why what does he do for you other than
give you dick
and buy you food that you have to go
pick up okay this is
for a year and a half all right you
already know what the [ __ ] i'm gonna say
but the the thing with the girl here is
like she's
she's she's feeling sick because she's
knowing she's she's doing this and she's
engaging in it i've been there girl let
me tell you
i've been there that's where this race
comes from i've been there so many times
that is where
the rage comes from because it's like me
getting angry
at the old me that's done that that's
right yeah
i've been through it i've witnessed it
i've been a part of it
so many times i can't even labeled it
i've enabled it terribly and
you don't love yourself
and you have to figure out how to love
yourself a lot of that
comes with realizing like what you're
like where did it start that
you decided that you weren't worthy of
love like where did it start that you
that you decided it was okay for someone
to treat you like [ __ ] like
you're gonna need therapy or you're
gonna need something that's gonna flip
the switch for you
because this is not healthy it's it's
gonna be really bad and it needs to end
as soon as it can
because at this point he can literally
either leave you or cheat on you and
just be like well you know we're never
my girlfriend anyway exactly
yeah yeah so why are you doing he's
trained you yeah
you guys are nothing you're like a dog
on a leash
walking around non-consensually even
though you think it's consensual like
you're literally
the gum at the bottom of my shoe and i
say that with the most
love that i can as a woman because i
want you to get better
and i want you to get out of that
situation because it's [ __ ] terrible
stop doing it being [ __ ] up yeah it's
super [ __ ] up yeah why are you doing
girlfriend things when you're not even a
girlfriend
exactly and not making him and then he
throws it into her face too and he's
just like
he'll he'll he'll give you that good jig
or he'll scare her too with like oh
let's talk to other people then like
like i'll give you a little bit and then
i'll take it away like it's that's
that's
sick now he's a piece of [ __ ] he knows
how much he you let him get away with
right yeah so he pushes it to the limits
and then continues to push it
oh yeah it's manipulation i remember i
dated a guy briefly when he didn't get
his whale
he'll be like i mean my ex-girlfriend
wouldn't do this i should just go talk
to her
yeah like that's manipulation right
there like oh you're not gonna do this
well
i'm gonna go and do this thing where you
can possibly lose me you better do what
i want that's so
[ __ ] it's disgusting it's ugly but you
need to take accountability
for yourself uh you need to get out of
the situation you need to get some
help and it's not like you're some
[ __ ] up person
you just you're you've fallen trapped to
something that a lot of girls fall
trapped to now you need to get yourself
out of the trap and don't
[ __ ] fall into the trap again like
men only act this way because we allow
them
exactly they get away with it and we
have to take accountability
for that so take accountability women if
you're a man and
or if you're a man woman whatever right
any gender right
uh if if someone's treating you shitty
your partner or whatever people get away
with it because they're getting away i
only speak from my perspective which is
um that of a female dating men so that's
obviously the
box i stand on right but yeah there's
some women that that take advantage of
men too
probably far less yeah the guys that are
like oh she only wants me for my money's
like you picked someone that only wants
you for your money like you wouldn't got
the money so you could get the girl and
now you're mad that you got she's with
you for your money like it's stupid take
accountability for yourself too
yeah like we're all like if you're being
treated like [ __ ] you don't like it you
have
standards and stick to those standards
you have standard like and it's
there's like some sort of scarcity
mindset i used to come from the scarcity
mindset i used to think
oh like especially timing too everyone
tells women at 30 you're just disgusting
yeah you're expired you're trash no
one's gonna love you so you better stick
with me like there's so much stuff
that we take in and we believe it and we
allow ourselves to be
just treated like [ __ ] disgusting no
you're not you're not expired you're
just waiting for those
divorce those hot deforesees
oh yeah all the good ones are taken so
once they're done with their first
marriage you swoop
well that means they weren't that good
down for no they could be great they
walked away from her
if she was terrible yeah you know the
very small
likelihood of that no yeah i i'm one of
those people who
i need to know i need to have that label
i need to you know and i'm not gonna
wait a year or something for that
[ __ ] that so i mean like i remember in
my past within like four months or so
i'm like all right what are we doing
like yeah am i going to be your
girlfriend or not
if i'm giving you that much energy and
it doesn't turn around these situations
don't turn into
like we will we will try
to make them turn into that relationship
we want it doesn't it doesn't
it doesn't change it's just a waste of
your time and energy you could be
investing in yourself
you know how much you find a better
partner how much mental energy she's
wasting now right yeah
and like back it up you see the strategy
you're doing so much like she's doing so
much girlfriend things one time a guy
asked me
oh do you want to bring your stuff over
to my house i'm like am i your
girlfriend
yeah no like i didn't want to put my
stuff at his house so why are you doing
all this stuff for him
stuff well is she doing it or is he
expecting her to
but she doesn't do it when she goes over
to his house he expects her to okay so
we don't know
if she's actually well he expects her to
because she's been doing it yeah why
else would he be expecting i was trying
to
i was trying
he does a bare minimum and for some
reason you think that's okay because you
don't want to be alone i get it i get a
girlfriend
but you're better than that you're
better than that that's that's the
lesson
that's right pack it up yep do do the
streets there you go
there we go she's tiffany what was it
against um
give us five stars on itunes you know
you want to
and uh we will see you next time make
sure you're following us yeah on
instagram instagram
so then you want to submit your
situation chip if you want us to tell
you to break up
you know tell you to break up we'll
confirm it for you no we'll validate
your feelings
yeah love you bye